(birds chirping)
- [Woman] Here in Nashville
we have 168 schools.
- [Woman 2] We have about 88,000 students,
124 languages are spoken.
We have historically had over 70 percent
economically disadvantaged
in our district.
In some of our schools
we had lots of tension,
some frustrations,
just realizing that we
weren't meeting the needs
of all of our students.
There wasn't an emphasis or a focus
on social-emotional learning.
- My first year, I had a
principal come up to me.
He said, "Kyla, I completely agree with
"social emotional learning and
I love the work you're doing,
"but I don't do hugs,
"so we're not gonna do this at my school."
It really made me pause and reflect
and think we don't even
have a common definition
of what social emotional learning is.
- Are we willing to work hard today?
- Yes!
- [ Kyla] So we worked on our
definition for the district.
We say that social emotional learning
are the skills that students and adults
have in order to be lifelong learners.
So their self-awareness,
their self-management,
relationship skills,
responsible decision making,
and social awareness.
- [Babs] There is a huge
and growing body of research
that shows that all great learning
happens in social context.
- I had one question.
- So, you really can't divorce
the social and emotional
from the learning.
- [Male Student] ...how
they, they just probably
say hello to her, just to, so they was...
- [Female Student] So, let's
answer some of these questions.
Have y'all ever felt like an outcast?
- Social emotional learning
is really about knowing
who we are as individuals
and giving us the skills we need
to interact with other people
in emotionally healthy ways.
- SEL is not separate.
Who in here was stressed
the last two weeks?
It's not just the time
that you might start
a five-minute lesson and do an SEL thing
at the beginning of class and
then that's where we leave it.
- [Female Student] This
line right here say...
- When you're going in and
seeing a Socratic circle,
they're demonstrating the
ability to communicate
and that is an SEL strategy.
That is helping them develop that ability
in a more effective way.
It needs to be ingrained and looked at
in all parts of the things
we do in the school day.
- It also has really
positive impacts on culture.
It helps build the skills
and mindsets that kids need
and also adults need to be pushed with
to be their best versions of themselves.
- Doing alright today?
- The district has supported us wholly.
They've given us the green light
to do things that are innovative.
Through our SEL department
we have a great team
that can come to the schools.
Sometimes it's just a
word of encouragement,
or can we come and see and give feedback.
(children talking)
- We have created a walkthrough rubric.
Helping schools see where they are
with the implementation process
and then we can support
the school at their level.
That really identifies SEL best practice
in three broad areas.
So first, we're looking
at school-wide community.
Is it inclusive?
How welcome do visitors feel?
How welcoming is it to the students?
Does it feel like this space
belongs to the students?
We also look at classroom instruction.
So how are teachers explicitly
integrating SEL in academics?
The teacher needs to know that, oh!
They expect that I'm gonna
make an engaging, active,
and interactive classroom environment.
In the third area we look
at with these walk-throughs
classroom environment,
management, discipline.
What are practices and policies
that are creating disparate discipline
that are disenfranchising students
and preventing those
students who need school most
from being in school every day.
Now we have much clearer
protocols and expectations
around restorative
practices in our schools.
- [Rachel] Across elementary,
middle, and high school,
you will see our students in circles,
talking and sharing.
- One commitment I
value is keeping myself-
- [Rachel] Other practices are group work,
really working together on a project.
Also making sure that there
are clear rules, definitions,
and procedures in place
so that students know
what the expectations are of them
and have that common
language among the teachers,
the students, and the community.
(hallway chatter)
- Our goal is to understand together
what each person's situation is
because this is a learning process.
Okay?
- [Babs] Every school receives
ACES awareness training.
- So, what happened?
And then we gonna talk about it.
- [Rachael] ACES are Adverse
Childhood Experiences.
- There's a lot of research out,
and there's a whole list of
things that are considered
to be events in kids' lives
that can cause trauma,
and so in order to reverse that trauma,
you have to do some
very intentional things.
- You guys have changed and grown up
so much this year and I'm so-
- So every schools really looking at
how can we create these safe environments
where kids wanna come to school,
where they can feel engaged,
where teachers are supporting children
whom come from a background
of trauma or chronic stress.
- [Rachael] We saw that we really need
to start with the adults.
If we don't have the knowledge,
it's hard to model
something for our students.
- Start with understanding
that it isn't a program,
it isn't a single strategy,
it's a paradigm shift.
It is understand the why behind it
and be able to communicate that
with the adults in the building.
- [Student] Thank you so much, Allie-
- It's our responsibility
to think through,
okay, how am I gonna make sure
that I have good, strong relationships
with everyone that I work with
and then model how to do that
with my peers and with my colleagues.
- [Babs] Whenever we pull adults together,
most of the time, we're
sitting in a circle.
- There's so much potential there.
- [Babs] We're checking
in with each other.
We're doing a mindful practice.
- In through your nose,
and out through your mouth.
- So, we're using those various strategies
that we're asking teachers
to go back to the classroom and use.
I think a real positive about our district
is that there's this top-down vision
of how we want our schools to be,
but there's also this grass-roots
kind of rising from the bottom,
where teachers are really
being very proactive
in advocating for students' SEL.
- Breathe in, breathe out.
- We have more and more
principals and school leaders,
and teachers wanting to be
trained in it and wanting more.
- [Student] You look fantastic.
- Fantastic?
- In Tennesse, we're in
transition right now.
We have people in our state
that don't believe that
social emotional learning
should be a part of our curriculum,
and metro-school is
still standing up going,
this is what we need to do.
- [Woman] Class been okay?
- Yep.
- It values our work and it gives us
the autonomy to say, "You can do it."
That takes courage,
and that takes the support of the district
and they've given that.
- You had a perfect day? That's awesome.